after 23-year career gp keith wallerson
faces the possibility
of being struck off after asking a
muslim woman to remove her veil because
he couldn't hear
what she was saying about her daughter's
illness he says
she removed it without complaint but
hours later her husband complained
about the gp's behavior saying his wife
felt racially abused
isn't it time we confronted the lie that
the veil the niqab and the burqa
are religious requirements they aren't
they have nothing
whatsoever to do with islam and nowhere
in the quran
does it say women should cover their
faces or their bodies
the veil is just a tribal invention
forced on women by misogynistic men
who want to keep them subjugated
segregated and oppressed
in britain's liberal democracy the veil
is an affront
to gender equality and by tolerating it
we're allowing a form of gender
apartheid
to develop in our midst yet still there
are those who celebrate it as a symbol
of our society's multicultural diversity
and tolerance well
actually it's one of the most sinister
developments of all times
the islam most muslims believe in wants
equality for women
those who believe in covering faces do
not
[Music]
cow last time i checked you're not
muslim are you
i'm married to wanju well you're not one
no i'm not one no i understand it well
let me finish okay the point
is throughout history women have been
oppressed through
put their clothes whether that be
corsets in the uk whether that be bound
feet in china and you know what it's
been women from those communities
themselves that have decided to champion
change
and i think it is not for you as a
western woman to impose your western
ideology
on somebody well whatever
let me finish it's not for you to impose
your ideas and your ideals
on of on billions millions of women
who are actually quite happy to wear
them do you think they're quite yes
let me tell you i've got somebody here
well i've got quite proud
so this is um a statement from molecular
geneticist
sahar al-faifi who is a phenomenal woman
who's on
television a lot and what she says is i
grew up
wearing the face veil as an act of
worship i live in a liberal
secular society that is politically
charged and highly divided
for me the face veil has multiple
meanings and dimensions
it is not reduced to a piece of cloth
nor is it exclusively a religious symbol
it is a symbol of my right my
right of self-determination resistance
and identity in the pluralist society to
which
i belong okay i keep hearing i keep
hearing this is about
i keep hearing this is about women's
choice to wear do they choose it
or let me finish do they choose it
or are they conditioned to wear it
choices people make
are are formed because of the say that
about how can you can you let me finish
your point
choices people make are conditioned by
their background by what they have heard
as they're growing up so if they grow up
among people who say
the veil or the burqa is a religious
requirement it's not there is no do you
understand the point that there is no
religious sanction for women to wear
burqas or face fields
none whatsoever in fact in fact let me
tell you that
uh al-hazal you know you pronounce the
brother the leading institution of
muslim theology in the islamic word
declared that the burger has no
spiritual authenticity
whatsoever and do not as a liberated
woman
see it as an oppression for a young
woman to walk around with a full face
veil and full
full black burger and three paces behind
her husband do you not think that's
enough i think it's
not for me to decide if that is the case
for her i would say yes but i don't
believe it's a choice
can i can i just say i think i think i'm
going to be the annoying person here
that tries to
uh chart a course through this debate in
a way that may hopefully
uh allow us to settle at terms and that
is the following
okay something can be a right an action
could be your right to do
without it being right to do it here
right and so i don't agree with banning
the booker no
i don't agree with buying it either i
want i agree with banging the face veil
sorry
that's what i meant repeat i don't need
that face fail
but i don't necessarily agree that it's
the right thing to do or where
but i will preserve somebody's right to
wear it precisely and the reason
why can i just interrupt you right there
why don't i have the right to wear
a a ski mask or a balaclava when i'm
walking through he's through a security
i will be told today so i've got
actually i've got a long column
going into all of this which is still up
online and uh i make an exception
for security sensitive situations so i
don't think face covering should be worn
in banks
in airports and in schools when you're
going to collect a child the teacher
needs to be able to identify that you're
the parent of that child but that's at
the moment that the identity is required
i don't think the french route is the
way we should go down because we're
british liberals
can we just hear from him before we go
to rachel so dr keith wolfson he said uh
the woman had a full face veil on which
i asked her to remove for clarity of
communication
there was no sign from her that she was
upset or upset with me for asking
she did so willing later on her husband
attended the treatment center
and made a formal complaint i'm not
racist this has nothing to do with race
religion or skin color i will say that
it's not related to race and therefore
calling him
racist is i think it's a sad indictment
of where the race debate is today
um this is more to do with culture than
race um therefore it's a bit easier to
debate what we're told is to do with
religion
but i don't understand about this debate
look a
tiny percentage of muslim women where
face spells the book of the nicotine
tiny percentage in the uk of muslim
women
and the thing i don't understand about
this debate is why we're so obsessed
with it
you know we spend so much time talking
about it politicians feel free to make
comment on it
newspapers constantly splashing on this
subject
and it has and it has the effect of
pushing the spotlight yes scapegoating
and focusing on women who we already
know muslim women
are more likely to receive uh racialized
hate and abuse
and the thing the thing about that is
the thing about that carol is that if
you really cared about women's
empowerment if i was
if i was a muslim woman who wore the
veil and was also facing social
exclusion i would think well why
why don't we talk about me being able to
get on a bus without being spat on
why don't we talk about me being able
why don't we talk about me being able to
go to
rachel rachel should this man
potentially lose his job no
no we're not talking about the article
no because it's not for me to decide
it's not my decision the medical council
is
actually saying that not all the
information is publicly available so i'm
not going to call it a different way
let's focus on this one issue because
what we do speak let him let him know
were he to lose his job would you
support that
if the council decided that it was
discrimination then i would support that
yes
i find that very so how can it be
discrimination to ask someone to remove
a veil
because that because he can't hear the
symptoms of a child's
illness no but no let me also just as
well you asked before why it matters
i'll tell you why it matters
it matters to social cohesion it matters
to social interaction
it because what what a veil is saying is
i'm different to you i'm separate to you
it poisons me that poisons relationships
in indigenous communities with immigrant
money it poisons and also let me also
say that behind it does not
talk about muslims why is it any of
why is it any of our business really i
mean live and let loose you have just
talked about
muslims being insulted and being called
names and being spat at this
exactly because because of the way that
we because of the way that muslims are
portrayed in our society
including the way muslim women is
you should not be wearing it in a bank
you should not be wearing it if you
collect a child in school you should not
but if you want and i agree it i i
celebrate the fact that we live in a
country where if a woman wants to walk
down and
go to the shops or whatever she'll go to
whatever she wants to do and she wants
her
she wears it that's great but i do not
celebrate the fact that a man with
20-plus years
could lose his job because
understandably to me he asked to listen
clearly to what the woman was saying
so i'm with magic's questions do you
think
i'm going to cover their hair i'm gonna
be i'm gonna bring you in and
all i want to say is for me and and you
and then you say it's nothing to do with
me but in
in this liberal democratic society in
which we live it is a fresh shock to me
every time i see a woman completely
swear but it is afraid
because she doesn't have to be and i
think many of
you say it's by choice i don't believe
it is every woman's choice
to wear the veil i really don't and i
think this this the case of the doctor
in pontia the woman was perfectly happy
to do it
she has a conversation with her husband
suddenly i'd rather live in
i'm sorry i'd rather live in the kind of
society where
somebody can wear a confederate flag
t-shirt and me feel
put off by that rather than ban them
from having the right to wear a
confederate now i'd never wear
a confederate flag t-shirt if i was a
woman i'd never cover my face i disagree
with it
in principle and in theology in muslim
theology you're right i don't think it's
mandated but they do
and that's the point it's their freedom
of choice to choose that
as an interpretation i don't think there
is any testing do you think we should be
free to win
i just wouldn't just as i wouldn't just
as i wouldn't ban the confederate flag
t-shirts for example i wouldn't ban a
face fail both i take objection to i
take issue to both and that's the kind
of society
i want to live and i want to be able to
live in the kind of society where
somebody can shock me by their dress
it's vicious used to shock people by how
he dresses it's a rare moment but i
agree with magic as well we finally got
there
i agree let's just end on that note of
agreement she just said she